Tương tâm dưới báo phía tưởng tủy văn cuốc gia cho biệt. Tương ngày hôm nay,
mình cảm thắc tư đến 1 chiến thăng tư, nhiều khu vực trên cả nước,
xuất hiện nắng nắng gây gắt của nơi đặc biệt gây gắt,
tìm bật muy cơ chảy nổ vài hưởng điet xức khoảng người dân.
Cú thể khu vực từ thành qua đến thành phủ đàn nắng và phía nông các tình
từ khoảng gái đến đất lắc, viên nhận nắng nắng gây gắt của nơi trên bún
mùi độ xe, như độ phù biến từ bà bài đến bà chiến độ xe,
luận thấp từ bà lâm đến của nơi phần chăm,
khu vực tế bắt bộ của nắng nắng nắng gây gắt,
với nhé độ phù biến từ bà sau đến bà tạm độ xe,
của nơi trên bà tạm độ.
Luận thấp từ bún lâm đến năm huy phần chăm,
trong khi đó năng đồng bằng bắt bộ,
cao nguình chú bộ và năng bộ dưới chí nắng nắng với nhé độ phù biến,
từ bà bà lâm đến bà sau độ xe,
luận thấp nhất từ năm huy đến năm năm phần chăm,
của quần khi tưởng cảnh bà,
nắng nắng kéo ra khi thập độ âm không khi giám thấp,
lần ra tăng quyết cây nổ và quán tải khu dân cư,
gió jukeau xe dùng điểm tăng cao,
đồng thời thời tiết khắc nghe cũng dễ gây mất nước,
anh hình định xe khỏe khi nghe dân tiếp xúc lâu ngoài chơi.
Các trình ra luy nhận độ thực tế ngoài chơi của thêm cao hơn
dự bào từ 2 đi bún lộ xe,
thăm chỉ cao hơn tại các khu vực có bề mặt hấp thủ nhật như bây tông đường nhợ.
Zodo áo gây dân cân trù đồng các biệt pháp phòng chánh.